perhaps the best part of get out is how
layered jordan peels academy
award-winning script
really is from subtle references and
hidden easter eggs to tiny moments that
only stand out upon close observation
here are some of the things you only
notice the second time
you watch get out after a disturbing
opening scene
get out cuts to chris's apartment where
he is preparing for his weekend getaway
with his girlfriend rose
as rose picks out pastries for their
trip at a local bakery
audiences hear childish gambinos red
bone
and during the opening credits there's
an incredibly ominous song playing with
lyrics in swahili
once you've seen the film and know what
is really happening at rose's family's
idyllic country home
redbone takes on a new meaning the
lyrics of the song remind listeners to
stay
woke and not close your eyes as for the
swahili song
if you take the time to translate the
song into english the lyrics tell you to
listen to your ancestors
which indicates that something
terrifying is just around the corner
the song then reappears during the
closing scene and
end credits just to reinforce the
message
right at the beginning of the film when
chris and rose hit a deer
chris goes over to the hurt animal and
seems like he's about to try and save it
later we learn that chris's mother was
hit by a car and bled
out on the side of the road when chris
was young as he tries to escape the
armitage house at the end of the film
chris's hang-up about hit-and-runs
almost gets him killed
when he hits georgina with his car
rather than moving on
he stops to pick her up which ultimately
results in her crashing the car
however in the end a deer comes to
chris's rescue in the form of an
enormous
buck's head mounted in the armitage's
basement dungeon
as he escapes captivity chris grabs the
head
and uses it to kill dean and in this
moment the deer gives chris his freedom
after rose hits and kills the deer on
the way to her family's estate
a police officer arrives on the scene
demanding to see chris's license
even though chris wasn't driving
incensed rose criticizes the cop for
targeting her black boyfriend
seemingly protecting chris from unfair
racial bias
however this moment hits differently
after you realize that rose is bringing
chris to her family's home as a means to
steal his body
and give it to a wealthy white person
rose isn't standing up to systemic
racism at all
she's simply trying to avoid a paper
trail since she and her family don't
want there to be any concrete evidence
that chris was with them when he goes
missing
though rose's parents dean and missy
armitage are welcoming enough when chris
and rose arrive at their home
there's sinister undercurrent to
everything dean
says when he takes chris on a tour of
the house during repeat viewings of the
film
it's pretty easy to spot the
foreshadowing present in nearly every
sentence dean utters
right away when chris and rose say they
hit a deer dean goes off on a rant about
how much he hates deer
i do not like the deer i'm sick of it
they're taking over they're like rats
if you take out the word deer his tirade
is chillingly similar to how racists
have been known to speak about black
people
then as dean shows off trinkets he's
picked up during his world travels he
says
such a privilege to be able to
experience another person's culture
of course later we learned that dean and
missy are literally
stealing black bodies taking cultural
appropriation to an entirely new
and horrifying level upon his arrival at
the armitage house
chris and the audience are both shocked
to see that the family has two live-in
black employees
which is a pretty unsettling discovery
dean even admits how problematic it
appears
but explains it away saying we hired
georgina and walter to help care for my
parents
when they died i just i i couldn't bear
to let them go
it turns out dean is being quite literal
since the film later reveals that
georgina and walter were actually
kidnapped by dean's parents
who took over their bodies dean has
another line that turns out to be
disturbingly
literal when he shows chris the kitchen
my mother loved her kitchen so we keep a
piece of her in here
of course that piece turns out to be his
mother's brain in georgina's body
throughout the film georgina and walter
occasionally reveal their true selves
if you pay close attention when missy
clinks her glass
georgina becomes startled and is quickly
sent away
indicating that the noise of the spoon
broke her hypnosis
chris later catches walter sprinting
through the house's grounds at night
proving that he's really dean's father
who's still trying to move past
losing a race to jesse owens in the
final act of the film
we learn the armitage's true plan every
time rose brings home a new black
partner
the family imprisons the unwitting and
unwilling donor
and steals their body for a white host
if it's your first time seeing the film
this reveal will come as a huge shock
however
upon later re-watches there's an easy
way to tell who's been stolen by the
armitages
all you have to do is look at their
hairline walter georgina
and andre are living evidence of the
armitage's twisted
end game and you can tell each of them
is hiding something because
they all hide their hairlines this
covers up the tell-tale scars they'd
have
after going under dean's knife georgina
disguises her scar with a wig
while walter and andre are never seen
without their hats
keeping up the ruse as the armitages
begin their annual party and secret
auction
chris wanders off with his camera
eventually coming across jim hudson
a blind art dealer who's friends with
the armitages jim tells chris that he's
familiar with chris's photographs
i am an admirer of your work you have a
great eye
it turns out the gym means the
compliment in a disturbingly literal
sense
when chris is captive in the
armatician's basement before his surgery
jim explains why he was determined to
win chris in the auction
i want your eye man
i want those things you see through not
only would chris as i give jim his sight
back
but he believes they will also give him
chris's talent as a photographer
one of get out subplots involves the
fact that chris smokes
much to the chagrin of rose and her
entire family
on their way to the armitage household
chris reaches for his cigarettes and is
immediately
chided by rose and when he arrives dean
tells chris that he also used to smoke
but after missy hypnotized him he never
wanted another cigarette again
missy offers to help chris with his
problem but he dimers
uncomfortable at the idea later that
night when chris finds missy drinking
tea in the living room
she brings up his smoking habit once
again telling him that it's not only bad
for him
but that she doesn't like him smoking
around her daughter
however the truth is that the armitage
family's concern for chris's health
is entirely selfish and manipulative
they don't care about chris personally
but they want to ensure that his body is
a perfect healthy vessel for whichever
white person wins the auction right from
the beginning
the armatic party is a weird experience
for chris eagle-eyed viewers may notice
that there are a few
key clues about what's really going on
right as all of the guests arrive
well before they make chris
uncomfortable with their strange
conversations
upon arrival all of the party guests
arrive in similar looking black cars
which takes on a new meaning when you
realize that every guest is there to vie
for a black body to drive around
then each guest warmly greets walter
which might seem odd since he's posing
as the groundskeeper
however once you learn that walter is
dean's father the original architect of
the entire experiment
it makes perfect sense the party guests
are simply greeting their old friend
throughout the armitage's garden party
chris is made extremely uncomfortable by
the other guests
who make awkward comments about race and
ask him invasive questions that seem
totally out of line
i do know tiger oh that's
great gordon loves tiger
oh best i've ever seen it might just
seem like these elderly white people
simply don't have manners
however it turns out that they're each
trying to decide whether or not to bid
on chris based on physical and societal
factors
black is in fashion beyond that the
color palette of the party has some
significance
many of the guests are wearing red black
or a combination of the two
representing both aggression and the
black bodies they steal
meanwhile chris is wearing a bright blue
shirt indicating a sense of calm and a
cool-headed nature
which is ultimately what gets him
through this horrible ordeal
before rose and chris ever arrive at the
armatic house the two joke about the
increased pressure on chris when it
comes to meeting her parents
he asks her if her parents know that
he's black worried it may cause a
problem
rose laughs saying her parents won't
care and brushes off
chris's concerns i don't want to get
chase off the lawn with a shotgun
you're not going to when chris is
getting ready to escape
she's the one who comes out the front
door pointing a firearm at him
when a briefly awakened walter uses his
final moments to turn the gun on his
captor
any horror fan worth their salt is
probably a fan of stanley kubrick's 1980
horror film
the shining and writer director jordan
peele is no exception
peel has made no secret of the fact that
the shining was a huge
influence on get out which is
unsurprising as both are social
thrillers about humanity's darkest
psychological impulses
inappropriately get out is peppered with
clever references to kubrick's
film right at the beginning of the film
we see a man taken hostage by the
sadistic jeremy armitage we later learn
his name is andre
and before he's abducted he mutters that
the suburban street is on
feels like a hedge maze this is a
reference to the overlook hotel's
frightening and ultimately deadly wintry
maze
later when chris's friend tsa agent rod
williams tries to check in on chris
a voice can be heard in the background
announcing flight 237
this is a clear reference to the
overlook hotel's most haunted room
just when chris's situation seems
irreversibly dire
he figures out a way to save himself
trapped in the armitage basement and
tied to an armchair with a recording of
missy meant to trigger hypnosis
chris is initially helpless thinking
quickly chris picks wads of cotton from
the arm rests of his chair
and stuffs them in his ears to keep
himself from being hypnotized
this allows him to keep his wits about
him so that he can seize the opportunity
to overpower jeremy when his restraints
are removed
the symbolism is pretty obvious calling
back to america's history of slavery
many slaves were forced to spend hours
in cotton fields painstakingly picking
cotton for their white captors
and get out that dark history is turned
on its head
when picking cotton freeze a black man
from white captivity
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one